en el sur de Turquía aquí uno de cada
cuatro habitantes es sirio y ya no son
bienvenidos el pueblo Turco quiere que
los indios se vayan ya los hemos acogido
bastante ahora el 95% de los turcos
quieren que los sirios se vayan
de Cara a la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales turcas el
discurso de la oposición se endurece
contra los extranjeros a los que ahora
acusan de Invasores delincuentes y
violadores en potencia pero este líder
local del partido republicano del pueblo
quiere mostrarse amable frente a la
prensa extranjera
primero debemos asegurarnos de que Siria
esté en paz y de que nuestros amigos
sirios puedan regresar de forma segura y
voluntaria
pero la estrategia está Clara aglutinar
a la extrema derecha ultranacionalista y
sus cinco por ciento de los votos a
pesar de su campaña sobre el miedo a un
gran reemplazo social
nosotros tenemos una media de dos hijos
por familia pero los tienen una media de
seis hijos no es natural a ese ritmo en
diez años controlarán todas las
administraciones de gaseantep como puede
aceptar esto nuestro pueblo estos
refugiados deben marcharse el año que
viene Esta es la primera y más
importante condición un discurso que
trivializa los actos de odio y racismo
en Turquía desde el comienzo de esta
campaña los sirios han mantenido un bajo
perfil en la ciudad Siria de dair el sur
el doctor munir era un médico respetado
antes de ser encarcelado y torturado por
el régimen aquí no es más que otro
extranjero que teme ser devuelto a sus
torturadores
psicológicamente es muy difícil para los
sirios en Turquía en este momento veo
televisión y tengo la impresión de
seguir la campaña incluso más que los
turcos no podemos acudir a la policía
primero para no causar problemas y
segundo porque sabemos que nadie nos
defiende bajo estas condiciones qué cree
que va a pasar si la oposición llega al
poder
toda la clase política siente esta
presión xenófoba el ministro del
interior asegura que los sirios son
hermanos pero que Turquía nunca se
convertirá en un depósito de refugiados